hello my name is Martin Blaser I'm a
professor of medicine and infectious
diseases at Rutgers University and this
is virus support I'm in my home in New
Jersey the filming crews are not here
because they're in self-isolation
and all by myself this normal kitchen
cleaner worked to clean a virus off a
surface or should I be looking to use
something more hardcore the good news is
that the virus is susceptible to many
different kinds of cleaners whether it's
soap and water or alcohol that's in
Purell and other products kitchen
cleansers Clorox or various chlorine
compounds cleaning things off even with
soap and water will do a terrific job in
a pinch you can use vodka given that
many people have had covin 19 without
knowing it is there a way to test
whether people had it the virus lasts in
a person for some number of days or
perhaps weeks and then it's gone after a
few weeks there'll be no way to detect
the virus itself but one can detect the
antibody response to the virus and
laboratories including our labs at
Rutgers are developing antibody assays
so we will be able to tell who's had the
infection we generally believe that
everyone who's had the infection is now
immune so that they will never get it
again if we're washing hands when we
come home from outside
shouldn't we be washing clothes too I'm
not aware of evidence that the virus
ever has been transmitted from clothing
and I think if it occurs it's very
infrequent you perhaps can lower the
risk from clothing by not shaking it in
the air that might dislodge the virus
clothing turns out to be very sticky for
viruses so if a virus gets to the
clothing it'll probably stay there
unless you dislodge it what actually
happens when you get corona virus so
it's like getting any kind of infection
or any kind of viral infection when the
virus comes into your body it starts to
multiply
and it keeps multiplying until your
immunity is able to eliminate it some
people never have any symptoms
whatsoever
some people have mild symptoms and some
people get more severely ill so there's
a lot of variation and that's something
and very important for the public to
understand probably most of the corona
virus infections that occur will either
have no symptoms or have very mild
symptoms and a place like the United
States may be a hundred million people
will get it in the next sub months so
even if severe infection is uncommon
those numbers add up weren't we warned
last year that people who are using too
much hand sanitizer and the result would
be super germs should we use it or not
usually should we limit how many times
we use it in a day in normal times when
you don't have a lethal virus that's
circulating you shouldn't wash your
hands too much because you're washing
off good germs that help protect you
against bad germs our body is full of
germs we call that the human microbiome
those are the bacteria that live in and
on our body and we live with these germs
all of our life we've inherited many of
them from our mother and she inherited
from her mother and it goes on for
thousands of years these our ancestral
organisms they help us find infections
they help us digest our food at present
we have a lethal virus that's
circulating we need to wash our hands as
often as necessary after we have
contacts that put us at risk so the two
really aren't contradictory it's all
based on the context of what's
circulating how do we handle the grocery
checkout with this virus spreading we
tap screens touch products pick over
produce grab freezer handles grasp
grocery card handles punch credit card
keyboards so we're using our hands all
the time and when we're in a public
place
every time we touch something we have
the chance of picking up the virus the
good news is that the virus doesn't go
through our skin but from the hands it
can go to our face and that's where it's
risky so after you have these exposures
in a grocery store or elsewhere you
should use a hand
sanitizer the alternative is to wear
gloves in public places where you're
going to be using your hands and the
good news for that is that you can wash
your gloves with soap and water and
reuse them many times I know you're
probably lying to me but is only one
strain going around when should we begin
to expect mutations so at this point
there are two major clusters there's the
original cluster from China from which
all strains are descended and then
there's a cluster that has been present
in Europe which is a variant of that at
this point most if not all the strains
in the US are related to that original
Chinese string but this is an active
area I wouldn't be surprised in some of
those European strains come to the US
emerge in the US as well how many tests
are available in the United States I
think everybody knows that we've had a
real problem getting enough tests up and
operating and although the number of
tests is coming up all the time it's
only a fraction of what we really need
we have a need for millions if not tens
of millions of tests because just about
everybody I know wants to know what's
their steps and especially if they have
any symptoms at all of COFF or fever or
sore throat or shortness of breath
shouldn't we start naturally calling out
to all recently retired but able doctors
nurses first responders EMTs and pull
them into emergency training to help
support our hospital staffs during the
crisis older people are at more risk for
severe manifestations of the infection
if they get so we're putting our people
on the front line who are at high risk
nevertheless you can think about this as
a war and we're at war with this virus
and there are people all the time who
volunteered to help and Wars for a good
cause so I don't think we should require
any retired people to do this because
they do have danger but if people
volunteer and they protect themselves
and they're aware of the risk I would
welcome their help I get food deliver
how long does the coronavirus stay on
plastic bags wear gloves when you're
taking things out of the plastic bags
and then throw the bags away if you
touch the plastic bags wash your hands
with soap and water then your wrist
should be zero I have a hypothesis
countries closer to the equator have
very low confirmed cases in the corona
virus one of the heat from the Sun
minimizes the rate of the spread it may
be that living in warm climates will
decrease how much virus infection there
is the virus has come to parts of the
world where it is warm so it's not that
there's no corona virus but it's
possible that the spread will be less
and that's why when warm weather comes
that may be one of the reasons why in
temperate parts of the world viral
infections go down the flu comes once or
twice a year then goes away Corona is
contact with any person infected right
so my question is this can you keep
getting Corona every time you fight it
off and then getting it again whenever
you're around another infected person if
you get one particular viral type in
general you're immune for the rest of
your life to that time but new types
keep emerging so this one
Sarris cofee - that's a brand new virus
it's never been present in humans before
and that's one of the reasons that it
sounds infections because no one has any
immunity to this virus until they
acquire it what we can predict if this
virus is like all other viruses and we
think that it is if someone becomes
infected they will never get this virus
again now if one or two years from now a
variant of this virus emerges that is
significantly different than the first
one then they could get that one that's
a little like what happens with flu
whether this Corona will lead to a whole
cycle like influenza does or whether
this is a one-time event nobody knows
what if you have a cold a regular
seasonal flu can you get the corona
on top if so as your immune system is
already stressed does that put you in
the vulnerable category can't find any
info on this when you have a viral
infection your immune responses are all
revved up and so usually you do not get
a second viral infection if you have the
flu and coronavirus lands on you
probably you're revved up immune system
will eliminate it now we don't know that
for sure but that's based on our general
understanding of infectious diseases
does the corona virus have a lifespan or
will it be seasonal the virus like the
corona virus will keep spreading to
people until it's it runs out of
somebody to go to that's why a social
isolation and Quarantine is so effective
we want to have as many dead-end
infections as possible the virus will
keep spreading if somebody has the virus
and they're in contact to someone who is
susceptible that is not immune so one of
the ways that epidemics end is that over
time the level of immunity in the
population builds up generally epidemics
end when 50 to 70 percent of the
population become immune to the virus
that's for a virus like influenza and
that's what we would expect for here
another way that we can increase the
immunity is to develop a safe and
effective vaccine the problem is testing
the vaccine because you have to test it
to make sure that it's safe with
vaccines there is the possibility of
side effects and there's also the
possibility that they will make an
infection worse instead of making it
better and for certain respiratory virus
infections like the influenza
there's a definite season it comes in
the autumn it's there in the winter it
dies down in this spring it's generally
at very low levels in the summer and
then it comes back in the fall so we're
hoping that good weather will slow this
down but then it could come back in the
fall just like other viruses do but at
least that might give us an extra six
months to develop effective treatments
or maybe an effective
I usually wash clothes in cold water
during coronavirus outbreaks does
washing including coats in hot water
help alleviate spread of the virus in
general washing is going to eliminate
the virus there's a dilution factor with
water any detergent lowers the virus any
use of bleach will eliminate the virus
so all these things together pretty much
make laundry free from virus
transmission so people that get the
corona virus and recover how long does
that last
anybody know one factor about this virus
is that the clinical course is extremely
variable that ranges from people having
no symptoms at all and many young
children are infected with the virus
they have no symptoms but they can
spread it if people who have mild
illness that lasts 3 days or a week and
some people are sick enough to be
hospitalized go to the ICU and some
people die as well so there's tremendous
variability if you get the virus and
you're recover you should be immune you
will never get the virus again then if
somebody's sick you can help take care
of that person because you're not going
to become infected so I'm assuming
coronavirus is the 0.01% that soap
sanitizers and disinfectants can't kill
this corona viruses are very susceptible
to soaps and sanitizers if they're used
if they're not used then the virus can
transmit the important take-home message
is that if people use soap and water or
hand sanitizer after they their hands
get exposed they will be largely
protected many doctors that know how
corona virus spreads is washing and
drying your hands with surgical gloves
on a good strategy or was that a serial
killer at the airport if you wear gloves
you will be protected from the virus if
you want to reuse the gloves just wash
them with soap and water and dry them
off and then you can use them again I'm
not sure what you mean by serial killer
at the airport I'm not aware of any
unusual events this guy just bought
three hundred dollars worth of toilet
paper am I missing something is the
corona virus
to have us all living in the bathroom
why is toilet paper more important than
food why are you not buying stuff to
keep you alive why do I not know the
secrets this happens before hurricanes
as well people start hoarding things
they're afraid they're going to run out
and somehow people got the idea that
toilet paper was in short supply so it's
gone from the supermarket shelves
everywhere because nobody wants to run
out of toilet paper I don't think there
there's anything special about this it's
just people panicking and their fear and
their hoarding behavior
so does Khurana not spread through the
air we know that the most important
route is spreading it is through
droplets the viral particles and the
droplets that somebody is coughing or
sneezing but we also know that it can be
said for people who aren't coughing or
seizing they have no apparent symptoms
so there is some airborne transmission
it's probably worse in small spaces like
classrooms or elevators and the like so
it occurs and that's why social
distancing is so important is there any
app yet which connects people who are
self isolating over the coronavirus and
have time on their hands and good Wi-Fi
with charities or individuals who have
jobs that need doing and if not can
someone please build one I think that's
a great idea
you know when you have calamity like
this there are all kinds of new
opportunities necessity is the mother of
invention and probably in this terrible
calamity there will be some good that
comes out of it I've been an infectious
disease specialist for more than 40
years this is unprecedented in my career
and I think it's really unprecedented in
the last century we have to go back to
the very terrible outbreak of flu around
the world in 1918 1919
to see something of this scale and
consequence social distancing isolation
quarantine these are all very important